hey it's Jos so last video I feel like I
had a bit of a contrived or maybe a bit
of a overly specific example we're
talking about gex spot the gex ladder
and today I want to speak in a more
General sense of what's going on uh
going through my head you know what I'm
thinking uh how I'm planning
execution you know how to actually use
this a little bit more practic Ally in a
broader
sense and the way I use it is very
similar to volume profile now for those
unfamiliar with volume
profile basically you take volume
transacted at each price you aggregate
it so you get rid of the time Dimension
and then you basically see where most
people have been
transacting uh and where that volume
tapers off and so like the classic way
of trading volume proog profile is you
know you're looking for the edges of the
distribution and your assumption is that
okay well historically you know people
aren't really willing to transact at
these
prices and so I'm expecting it to return
to where people are willing to transact
so you're looking to fade the edges
right um you know so this is range trade
and then there's the break out trade
where you're looking for exits from
these
distributions and you're looking for
traversal across low volume areas to
some other node or an hvn high volume
node so gex is the same
thing literally the only difference is
that these are live
positions and they're not historical so
so you get to see with the bird's eye
view you know before we reach some level
whether or not people are angling for
some area or where they're positioned
you know as a pivot
right so when I'm looking at this all
I'm doing in my head is
segmenting positive versus negative or
call versus put gam right so we have
this
distribution we have a pivot here this
little put bar
um I'm thinking about transition areas
too right where it's positive there's
one bar that's sticking out in the
opposite
direction uh we have a small positive
distribution here and then it's mostly
puts right and here's are
Majors so ideally or the the rule of
thumb generally is okay if we're inside
some
distribution and of course there there
are many pivots to inside here right
either places to trim or to
flatten um these are convexity Peaks
right so you know an options perspective
maybe this is where someone's hitting
the belly of that curve on their
contract and they're looking to take
profit right so if you're trading
Futures it might also be a good idea to
trim a
position anyway I'm thinking okay so if
we're in in some distribution I'm
looking to
take
Longs towards major if we're accepting
into this area right if I'm short
biased uh then I'm looking for pivots
right so I'm looking for transition
areas like this and this so either I'm
looking for ranging
action then an Impulse
high at this put
bar I can join it
and then look for continuation short
continuation right or if we've already
accepted into this
area there's always these local versals
right local revisions where you come
down to some bar we pull back then I'm
looking for you know this is my line of
the sand between these two
distributions where I'm hoping that or
I'm Angling for a short continue as long
as we maintain this line of the sand and
then we can continue down with generally
my targets
being the
majors right so this is where either
we're
trimming or you're taking you know your
core here and then you're leaving a
runner or you're flattening right these
are kind of like the targets effectively
and yeah that's basically it I think
that was a little too simple maybe but
I'm going to keep making these as we
go I do have an example from
today sort of the thought
process it's really short and sweet I
promise so today we
open inside the previous day
range and immediately we see this
positioning at 57
and then we see this at
230 which was also overnight
high now again thinking about
distributions
right I'm seeing this bar this put bar
this is all negative it's all put gamma
and then it there's a transition it
changes positive there's a put bar and
then positive now we're inside this
distribution
so I'm looking for short
scalps to Major
257 and in this example I'm actually not
looking for any sort of breakthrough you
know
so I came into this with a pretty strong
short
bias uh but I know that did not align
with the context right so it's a Friday
we just had a week of pretty serious
selling and generally you know we're you
know Fridays you're going to see some
sort of volt Crush right you're going to
see some sort of bid to cover some sort
of ramp and some sort of ridiculous
squeeze right so at the very most and I
can't change my bias right I'm I'm bias
short I think it's fine to have a bias
that doesn't align with context it's
just important to
not let it get in the way of execution
right or to know to to sit in her
hands so with that in mind all I'm
looking for are just scalps to this
level and I'm not trying to I'm not even
going to leave a
runner to go because I know it's going
to bounce I know that it's very likely
I'm gonna get stopped at break even and
even on a runner that just you know it's
a prone to tilt type of style
right so all I'm doing is just taking
the scalps to that level obviously in
hindsight you know the optimal trade was
okay well it's probably V Crush Friday
or'll probably see a bunch of short
covering just look for bids off of this
level right look for a long and look for
that ramp to that transition level or to
Major positive for your
Runners uh but at least for me in this
even with that context in mind I felt
like okay well we had like prior day
close down here PRI day low here very
easily we could have gone down to these
levels as well even with this
positioning in the way so it just wasn't
ideal in my head to look for those Longs
um and when you know the action was
generally pretty whippy this morning so
those shorts were much quick to to pull
off rather than you know we did
eventually ramp off of 57 but you would
have been waiting there for like a
[__] hour I think like two hours it
was past like IB
close but yeah I think that's it for
this video uh I hope that provides some
value and yeah see you next time